[Música]
salud tendría hecho américa france24 me
acompaña en el estudio más romeros a la
mar bienvenida feliz mañana de miércoles
y este tema no le va a gustar mucho a
las personas que son obsesionados con la
limpieza digamos con las bacterias con
los microbios porque porque en eeuu hay
algo una información muy importante
estas superbacterias buenos días raúl
efectivamente en esta área en este caso
si coincide la el nombre amenazante con
la situación también verdaderamente
amenazante son unas bacterias que son
resistentes a los antibióticos y a otros
tratamientos antibacteriales a raíz pues
de haber evolucionado y haberse haber
podido eludir como las ataquen este tipo
de fármacos la información es que en los
centros de control y prevención de
enfermedades de eeuu han finalmente
publicado unos datos que ya
anticipábamos desde hace un tiempo y es
que en el año de la pandemia en 2020 las
muertes por está por infecciones de este
tipo de bacterias aumentaron aumentaron
un 15 por ciento en total 29 mil 400
personas que murieron por infecciones de
este tipo de bacterias 40 por ciento de
ellas en infecciones hospitalarias es
decir que se contagiaron
una estadía en el hospital que nos dice
este dato pues primero que hubo
muchísimas más hospitalizaciones a raíz
del cob y 19 en 2020 que en 2019 es uno
de los motivos por los cuales aumentaron
los casos pero no es el único también
hay un reflejo de un problema de más
años desde hace tiempo de usar
antibióticos para todo de una forma
relativamente irresponsable y además de
algo que veremos acelerado también por
la misma pandemia porque recordemos que
durante mucho tiempo por esa confusión
que a veces existe entre los virus y las
bacterias las personas que intentaron
combatir la infección de kobin 19 y de
su virus del sars cop 2 con antibióticos
se consumieron mucho y eso acelera que
las bacterias desarrollen esta
resistencia aaron mal y digamos que no
fue a esperar en el futuro a causa de
esta resistencia de las bacterias a los
antibióticos pues básicamente son
infecciones que entonces no se pueden
tratar que eso sucede con algunas
enfermedades infecciosas que están
provocadas por las bacterias como la
tuberculosis pero también pueden darse
otras situaciones por ejemplo las
operaciones que no se van a poder hacer
porque haber riesgo de infecciones o
enfermarse gravemente por cortes o por
infecciones que hoy en día son
perfectamente tratables de hecho se
calcula que si no se hace nada de aquí
al futuro en un futuro de mediano plazo
podrían llegar a morir unas 10 millones
de personas anuales por estas
superbacterias recordemos que es un
proceso relativamente natural que no es
que sea nuevo y es que eso las bacterias
pues evolucionan debido a que son
organismos que van cambiando y se van
adaptando a su entorno pero esto debe
ser contrarrestado con investigaciones
encontrar nuevos fármacos nuevos
antibióticos y porque esto no está
sucediendo en parte hay otros motivos
pero en parte porque el mercado de
antibióticos no es rentable para las
farmacéuticas no al final los
antibióticos es un tratamiento de 4 o 5
días una semana de unas pastillas que
luego te terminas de tomar porque te has
curado es mucho más rentable investigar
en tratamientos de por ejemplo
enfermedades crónicas el cáncer sin ir
más lejos y aquí por recalcar que es a
veces una de las consecuencias de dejar
la investigación y también la producción
de fármacos en manos privadas que se
guían al final pues por los propios
intereses económicos más dejamos lado
estas superbacterias para pasar a otro
tema porque hay datos que indican que
los oxímetros podrían estar leyendo mal
a las personas que no son blancas así es
raúl de hecho no es la primera vez que
se aporta evidencia de esto y no se ha
hecho nada al respecto recordemos que
los oxímetros son esos aparatos que se
ponen el dedo para medir pues la
saturación de oxígeno en la sangre saber
si esa persona tiene oxígeno o no se
trata de un estudio con datos de
unidades de cuidados intensivos del
hospital de un hospital en boston se
publicó en la revista médica llama y
básicamente cuando revisamos aquí las
cifras es un coeficiente que sale de
varios cálculos y que si cogemos el cero
como referencia el cero sería que pues
el oxígeno que marca el aparato es el
mismo que el oxígeno que tiene la
persona en sangre vemos que hay una
disparidad no sobre todo en personas
afroamericanas tienen mucho más tiene el
perdón el oxímetro marcaba un nivel
mucho más alto del que realmente tenían
es decir que la información estaba
errada pensaban que estaban oxigenando
mucho mejor de lo que realmente estaban
y eso también se traduce en que el
suministro de oxígeno entonces en
personas racializados personas que no
son blancas también fue menor pues por
qué sucede esto repasemos no el oxígeno
el oxímetro perdón lo que hace es mandar
como una luz infrarroja y roja a través
del dedo y eso puede medir la cantidad
de oxígeno que en la sangre porque la
sangre con oxígeno la refleja y la
absorbe de una forma distinta a la
sangre que no tiene oxígeno pero qué
pasa que sabemos que el pigmento de la
piel de hecho incluso tener las uñas
pintadas de negro puede interrumpir o
hacer que eso no funcione bien no se ha
hecho nada al respecto a pesar de
saberlo y también pues de nuevo es un
ejemplo de lo que sucede cuando se asume
que todo el mundo es blanco o se hacen
instrumentos pues sólo para esa
población y termina bajo una alarmante
recomendación de las autoridades island
acá si de hecho es unas palabras rápidas
que diremos desde la asociación médica
perdón de sri lanka recordemos que el
país está en una crisis profunda
política y económica llegaron al punto
de decir que no se enfermen no se
lastimen no hagan nada que los podría
llevar al hospital de forma innecesaria
porque pues porque no hay suficientes
tratamientos y eso no solo es por la
crisis política actual o por una cierta
inestabilidad sino por la crisis
económica que lleva pasando desde hace
meses no solo en sri lanka también sino
en muchos lugares del
no solo afecta además a heridos
ocasionales o enfermedades puntuales
sino sobre todo a personas con
enfermedades crónicas también por
ejemplo de nuevo cáncer o enfermedades
de riñón que necesitan tratamientos
constantes también es un buen momento
para recordar que al final todos estos
avances que se hacen en salud por
ejemplo de la pnc había aumentado tres
años su esperanza de vida desde el 2000
había llegado a los 75 años de esperanza
de vida también había eliminado la polio
o la malaria gracias a unas amplias
campañas de salud todo esto es muy
frágil y requiere un trabajo y un
esfuerzo constante de las autoridades y
puede tener todos estos tratamientos que
ahora mismo podrían verse afectados
todos estos avances y todos estos
trabajos pues porque no hay
abastecimiento de cosas que se necesitan
de tratamientos que se necesitan